[Music]
dog towns airstrip southern Utah trainer
Cheri Woodard in dog town manager
Michelle bez Minh are headed to Omaha
Nebraska
we're ready for anyway
the Nebraska Humane Society has just
rescued 150 dogs from a dog breeding
facility we were actually contacted and
told that the shelter where these
animals had landed was overwhelmed and
they needed help
as soon as they arrived Sheree and
Michelle are briefed on the dog's
condition mostly they're very filthy
animals covered in life they are very
matted we're pretty much Shaving most of
them down we also have found parasites
of every kind they come from a puppy
mill a commercial dog breeding operation
puppy mills are places where people
factory farm puppies
they are kept in cages they are not
handled and they are bred and their
babies are taken away often underaged
and sold to pet stores to brokers and
online dog towns experts are often
called in by shelters across America we
were asked if we would be willing to
take on the most challenging the dogs
that they knew would require the most
work there's one dog in particular a
little black Terrier that attacks
anything near him he just bit one of his
friends
[Music]
their first challenge kenneling the dogs
for transport they sure did okay thank
you they done welding gloves and move
into the Pens you ready
this one will buy very heretical several
times he might be flying through the air
it's still an option sweetheart wanna
okay sweetie hey hey hey sure he's gonna
stay in this thing like you am an
alligator in head you know all right
scruff shouting okay he's looking for
the opening he is okay here we got you
baby it's daybreak at dog town trainer
sherry Woodards house she spent the
night with the ten dogs rescued from the
Nebraska puppy mill they're all um
except for one they're crated in my
kitchen right now she names the
aggressive black Terrier animal Sherry's
challenged with animal domesticating him
teaching him not to be terrified of
people was very sad to me it's hard to
see animals that don't have skills at
all and have been living in fear and
think the worst of what's going to
happen when people are nearly
in the puppy mill animal lived in a two
square foot cage
he couldn't escape his own filth he
didn't have other dogs to teach him
normal canine hygiene animals fur is
almost solid with dried urine and feces
sorry this is awful
we gotta get
[Music]
they have no idea that we're trying to
help them blind kind of panic of
screaming and thrashing and trying to
get away
[Music]
neutering reduces a dog's aggression
sherri hopes it'll make animal easier to
Train a lot has to happen at certainly
in the beginning and some of its not
pleasant so we'll try to try to balance
it out actually will try to go heavy on
the good stuff so lots of really yummy
food and space to move around other dogs
to build relationships with it'll take
him a while we ended up needing to shave
animal and I kept as much of the hair on
his ears and on his face as I could
thinking that that would help him to
feel more comfortable that he wouldn't
have the huge change to not having hair
over his eyes which is how he hasn't
it's a clean start for animal a new look
and share he hopes the start of a new
life but he just wants to know
[Music]
the little Terrier has recovered from a
surgery he's more comfortable without
his matted fur most important he's
becoming attached to Shari I think he
still has strange moments when he
clearly doesn't have it right
he doesn't have normal behavior
sometimes but I think he's beginning to
figure it out and soon he'll start to
figure out who he is and who he wants to
be today's his first venture into the
world outside her house there we go the
garden outside dog towns Welcome Center
is a vast place to a dog who's lived his
entire life locked in a cage he has a
bold side that must be genetics and then
he has a lot of fear so I don't ever
know what to expect which side is going
to come out he has moments of panic
which are clearly fear and then he has
moments when he truly seems like he's
getting it animal is still an unknown as
what we will see as he makes progress he
could surprise everyone and become close
to normal which would would surprise me
would be amazing I want to be hopeful
but only time will really tell us what
what he can do and what he what he
ultimately will become even better